the Joe Rogan experience sweet we did a
stunt on fear factor once where you had
to they were suspect they were off a
bridge and they had to hold just hold
themselves like on a chin-up bar over
bridge and the girls all beat the guys
wait they were they were just hanging
just hanging not just himself nope well
just hanging huh just holding on the
girls all beat the guys the all three
guys fell now it was like part of me was
like maybe these guys are just [ __ ]
but part of me was like well the thing
is like the guys they're pretty big
dudes they're all around 200 plus pounds
and you know that's a lot of weight in
your hands and the girls are like 120
110 105 it's not as much weight there's
there's a genetic thing between men and
women where there's some things that
like we all we see these in sports and
whatnot they're some sports that are
just much more fun to watch when madam
playing or some sports yeah playing
there's some sports that are both right
right but um there's something I forget
the test exactly but it's something
about leaning over and picking up a
cheer there's a certain posture that
you're in and men can't do it but women
can oh like you can't and but it's like
a folding chair like very very light
cheer I don't know I don't lean it's
over and picking up it yeah so like
you're leaning I think you press your
head onto the wall but arch your back in
a certain way and you you just have to
use like your lat space that you pick up
the chair Nick and men can't do it
really yeah how weird yeah it's like a
center of gravity tests I remember just
oh you know my daughter tried to show me
this the other day trying to get me to
touch my toes with keep my back flat
against the wall with the back of my
legs against the wall and go down touch
your toes you just fall for yeah see
that's that's see I had it all backwards
all right put your butt against watch
your head that's not you sticking my
butt up against stuff let me see that
Lucy tricks guys can't do stand three
feet away from a wall bend over put your
head against the wall now try to stand
up while lifting and chair oh no you had
it okay that's a couple different dishes
so yeah couples are on the center of
gravity though
oh yeah that's the one I'm gonna try I
feel like I could do that that's that's
that's what I said yeah I mean I don't
think I'm being cocky and saying I could
do that but what if a guy's got like
really good core strength I don't think
it has nothing to do with that yeah just
all about center gravity yeah because I
think not most guys but like you take a
bunch of fit guys they have a good
strong core they can't do them they
can't do it hmm
like you take the average woman
congratulations on your victory ladies
you got us on one yeah like I don't want
to spend to this subjects where I'm like
I don't want to say anything smart-assed
or anything any kind of way cuz I get
myself in trust so much trouble to get
into today see so many different things
people get mad and upset about they did
a test with the way that men and women
do a one-legged squat and I guess the
way that each of us would go down is
completely different when you have when
you break it all the way down to that
move oh so like the mechanics and yeah I
said because the hips muscle structure
everything yeah it probably is that both
women the the it's so different the way
the shape of their hips though the
mechanic like women kicking that's
that's one like for every valentina
Shevchenko that can knock someone out
with one kick yeah you would think that
a woman right take a hundred and forty
pound woman who is carrying a hundred
and forty pounds with her legs all the
time going up flights of stairs running
doing all these different plyometrics
and [ __ ] you would think that [ __ ]
could be able to kick a [ __ ] hole
through you see there's another what
used the word [ __ ] that's okay that
it's out of respect that's not it that's
not derogatory but know like if you see
a girl kick a bag like there's a giant
difference between a 140-pound girl
kicking a bag 140 pound guy big
difference and now now is it mostly
technique or is it you know by oh I
think it's biomechanics
I think it's technique I think it's just
muscles this they're just built
different there's just different muscles
like the hips are like this right
well hips especially for minutes wide
hips right or their hips go out wide and
their legs kind of go in a little bit or
is it got I wonder if that's responsible
for the what they call that the male
spread when dudes sit on
sit on a subway and they spread the lamb
and spread yeah
the man spread and people get real mad
cuz they want to sit next to you yeah
your legs are all splayed out you're
being rude but if a dude has no one next
to them that's how they say yep their
legs spread I don't think women sit like
that I don't think I don't think it goes
that way I don't like sitting like that
that's like as I sitting and like I've
sat in coach most of my life you know
and like that's that's it's
uncomfortable like when you have to sit
like that for an extended amount of time
yeah it's really uncomfortable with your
legs pinned together yeah
yeah it's weird yeah and then they're
sometimes but after a while you just you
you just feel uncomfortable inside your
pants you got them we had a move stuff
around you can't even open your legs to
do that but with women I think that's a
normal way to sit I think their body
naturally with their hips in the shape
that there are the legs kind of go
towards each other they kind of point
towards the knees it's more normal for
them to sit with their legs together I
think that makes sense it makes sense I
just I wonder if it has to do with
anything that the equipment down there
oh yeah probably us - not wanting to be
a hoe right I sit like this with your
legs spread if a dude sits like that
that's a confident man but if a girl
sitting there with a legs be like look
at this [ __ ] there's another you
scientific article of explaining man
spreading this is a spinal neurosurgeons
explanation thank you spinal
neurosurgeon Jon see overall width of
the pelvis is relatively greater in
females and the angle of the femoral
neck is more acute these factors could
play a role in making a position of
sitting with the knees close together
less comfortable for men exactly
so all you manspreading people that are
shaming men for sitting in a natural way
how dare you
[Applause]